hey what's up guys I'm body and welcome
to the second part of the Q&A video that
I posted a little while ago so basically
in the first video I said they asked me
a lot of questions about Dark Souls 2
because I've actually played quite a bit
of it and you know that video aired
about three months ago and since that
time I've learned a lot about Dark Souls
2 so you're going to get a lot out of
this video but on that video the most
popular question has actually become
where the [ __ ] is the answers video so
without further ado here it is so the
first question comes in from submersed
raishin he says hey buddy
I wonder did you experience any kind of
disappointment playing Dark Souls 2 this
is a good question because all the
videos on my channel are usually made
with a focus and very rarely does that
focus involve nitpicking about little
things so I'm glad I can talk about some
of the things I was disappointed with
that said very little disappoints me in
this game anyway the two things that
come up first when I think of
disappointment is the travel system and
also just movement so we'll talk about
the travel system first you know when
you light a bonfire it acts as a
checkpoint well now every single bonfire
you like acts as a checkpoint and now
you can travel to every single bonfire
like straight from the start of the game
no Lord verse will required so this is a
great thing because it really trims down
the fat in the game and I do appreciate
it like it makes you go to different
areas and experience them if you're
having trouble with an area you're
having trouble progressing or you're
just sick of the environment you just
travel to a different area and progress
there and the game is designed so that
you can go any direction you like so
having the travel to every bonfire
option is great because you don't have
to go a specific way and you can just
travel there immediately and explore a
different area and that's awesome the
thing that's bad about it is that you
don't actually spend much to try and
traveling between bonfires arc Souls one
you know you could travel to some
bonfires but you still have to do a lot
of walking between them and in Dark
Souls 2 that just doesn't seem to be the
case and that means you miss out on
finding random things in the world you
might not have otherwise found and you
do spend a lot of the game traveling but
my opinion on this might change as I
play more of the game and there is
definitely an upside to it and the game
design reflects that now the second
thing that disappointed me was movement
and
I think generally the movement looks
great I think the motion capture they've
got with it looks great and I know a lot
of people say oh it looks too floaty but
I think it looks really realistic the
thing I didn't like about the movement a
long time ago when I played the beta and
a few of the other demos was when you
hold the controller and you know you
push left on the analog stick there was
a bit of input lag between you pushing
left and your character actually moving
left in Dark Souls one movement was
really tight as soon as you push left on
the analog stick you know your character
move to left but in Dark Souls 2 I felt
a bit of a delay however in more recent
versions of again it's much tighter than
it was before but still not up to Dark
Souls levels of tightness so while I am
a bit disappointed with these two
aspects of the game that's just two
aspects out of many and I think the
sentiment of Dark Souls 2 being a great
game is shared across all the people in
the community that have played it like
epic neighbor I know for example thinks
it's better than the first Dark Souls
and from what I've played I'd have to
agree with so the second question comes
in from dr. no-name and he says how is
the dual wielding is it good as in how
it feels and looks so the dual wielding
and Dark Souls 2 is so much different
from Dark Souls 1 now if you want you
can actually use a weapon in your left
hand as if it was in your right hand and
what I mean by this is that your move
set is just mirrored for l1 and l2 just
like it is on r1 and r2 that gives
anyone who jewel will so much variety
and there's actually another aspect of
dual wielding which is the power stance
power stance is something you get when
you hold down triangle and you're
holding two weapons they're the same
weapon class so if I'm holding two
bandit knives they're both the same
weapon class of dagger and if I hold
down triangle I'll go into a unique
stance where I hold them a bit
differently and then l2 will allow me to
attack with both of them at the same
time so there is so much variety with
dual wielding and I'd say it's almost as
viable as using a shield it makes a
character really offensive but you get
so many different attack options by
holding two weapons so it's a really
brilliant change so next question user
Dark Souls rs says is there a heart
normal and easy mode setting because in
a network test they changed it to a hard
mode where the enemies did
damaged and had a lot more health I hope
this was just ng+ testing that it might
have been a difficulty slider there is
no difficulty slider in Dark Souls 2 but
ways to change the difficulty are built
into the game and I'm not going to spoil
how they're built into the game but I
found 3 different ways to change the
difficulty in the game and I've only
played maybe half way through and from
what I can see they don't just change
the health enemies have will have to
experiment but I think they actually
changed the way the enemies behave and
one of them definitely does there's so
many reasons I love this more than just
choosing easy hard ultra mode it's so
much better you know in Dark Souls there
was that ring you could use from
kalameet that made enemies do more
damage it's like that in the sense that
it's built into the actual game by
making it a part of the game by
interacting with things that change the
difficulty it gives the difficulty
slider a sort of organic feel but more
than that it doesn't seem like this just
changes the health and damage of enemies
it seems like this also changes the
behavior of enemies and if you've seen
my Dark Souls modern series you'd know
that that's the best way to increase
difficulty not just by artificially
increasing the health or damage no by
changing their behavior you basically
change the entire game and the amount of
longevity this will give to Dark Souls 2
is pretty staggering so next question by
bought heck he says what strategy seems
the most viable so far by this I mean
sorcerer cleric strength deck set cetera
so from my time with the game I think
for the first playthrough I'm going to
go with the decks in to build it seems
like the best built especially for the
early game because when you use a
strength build in Dark Souls you know
you have to lug around a really heavy
weapon and at the early game at least
you have really low endurance or
vitality you know you can't roll really
easily with a heavy weapon so while I
think strength builds and using heavy
weapons will be great in the late game I
think the best thing to do for the early
game is go for a dex build and from what
I've seen of pyromancy and spells I'm
going to want to try out intellect as
well so personal favorite that's index
into build everything seems really
viable though if you use a bow you can
move [ __ ] shooting it uses stamina now
and if you're
Master you can cancel the cast halfway
through you can increase the speed of
your casts by increasing attunement
there's so many different spells now I
really feel like they tried to focus on
making every play style viable and that
shines through in the gameplay this next
question comes in from the macaques
where is the answer video here and the
next question is mr. sketch Oh 9 I'm
curious about weapon upgrades did you
see anything that hinted at how this was
going to look so weapon upgrades very
similar to Dark Souls in that you use
tide knight to upgrade the one major
change though and the thing that I like
is that it's a bit more streamlined now
and what I mean by that is you know in
Dark Souls when you had to get the large
ember to push your weapon from plus five
to plus six or the very large ember to
push it from plus ten plus 11 I'm pretty
sure they've got rid of that now and
it's just seamless all the way up to
plus 15 in terms of elemental weapons
and stuff I don't know but that change
alone makes the game easier for new
players to understand and doesn't
compromise on anything so I'm glad they
took that out when is this coming out on
DS Lite the next question comes in from
into the caramel frappe who asks will
covenants allow you to submit your gifts
all at once as much as I love Dark Souls
sitting there for 10 minutes giving one
gift at a time when the requirement for
rank 3 is 80 is time consuming if we
could place the amount we want to give
that would mean a lot I'm pretty sure
this is in the game for covenants
because it's definitely in the game for
souls if you have a number of consumable
soul items like for example 5 souls of
the Lost Knight you can consume them all
at once or you can consume them one by
one so this functionality is in the game
so I'd be surprised if they didn't apply
that to covenant rewards strawberry
donut Kane asks are there Sun Bros there
better be some robes there are some
froze next question comes in from
gangsta 301 who says our strength
weapons being buffed or nerfed in Dark
Souls 1 I think strength weapons were
definitely in need of a of a buff they
were slow and especially in PvP
they were so easy to avoid just because
the swing speed was so slow in Dark
Souls 2 they've improved them in a
really significant way the swing speed
is faster
they're really heavy which is a bit of a
downside and that hasn't changed but
they do seem better is also a new
mechanic where if you use a strength
weapon and if you up your strength it
becomes easier to break enemy guards and
if you break an enemy guard they
basically go into a riposte able
animation where you can go up to them at
a bar one and you score a critical hit
on them I'll try to put some footage of
this on screen but this is an awesome
change it means buffing strength
actually does more than just change the
damage it does it means that if you are
a strength build you'll be trying to
break the guard of enemies and that's a
huge change so yes there are starting
gifts in Dark Souls 2 and from what I
can tell so far there's nothing like the
master key although I can't be sure
anyway the gifts are life ring human
effigy healing wares homeward bone seed
of a tree of giants bonfire ascetic and
petrified something the last three are
particularly interesting the others are
just consumable items that help with
your playthrough but the last three are
interesting see to the tree of giants we
don't know what this does I haven't
found out what it doesn't I probably
wouldn't tell you one for aesthetic
though increases the difficulty of
enemies around a bonfire so you burn
this item in a bonfire and enemies
around the bonfire become more difficult
so like I mentioned before this is a way
to increase the difficulty of the game
I'm not sure how they become more
difficult whether it's health or damage
or just aggressiveness but the fact that
this is in the game from the very start
that's a pretty cool feature the last
thing is petrified something and we
don't know what this does either I don't
know what it is but from what I can tell
unpaid refined things is a thing in Dark
Souls 2 and if there was anything I
would choose it would probably be one of
those last three just because we don't
know what they do yet and it seems like
you figure out what they do later in the
game the next question comes in from
altra combo who says prequel or sequel
it's a sequel but we do know that time
travel plays a part in this game so
we'll see stay a while and listen says
is the resistance step of p in the game
like if you put 30 in will the enemies
still be able to damage you so
resistance was in Dark Souls 1 and it
was pretty terrible resistance used to
be in Dark Souls
but it's not anymore resistance has been
merged with agility and now they've
become a stat called adaptability what
adaptability does is a it makes your
character move faster in always so
parrying is faster raising your shield
is faster drinking arrest is faster all
those things come with adaptability and
the other way adaptability affects your
character is with what resistance used
to be so if you up adaptability you'll
also take a bit less damage from attacks
especially small attacks like arrows and
daggers and things that sort of chip
away of your armor I think raising
adaptability now makes it so that those
things do a lot less damage and is it
overpowered it should be considering all
the things it does but I think they've
actually scaled it down quite a bit so I
don't think it's overpowered anymore but
it is a really good stat don't
underestimate it the next question comes
in from sprek 41 do you know if Dark
Souls 2 will release for PC at the same
time or later than the consoles Dark
Souls for PC is coming later than
consoles the thing is we don't know
exactly when yet Amazon's got it listed
as may 31st which i think is way later
than it will be I think May 31st is the
latest we will see Dark Souls 2 on PC
and that's probably why Amazon has
listed it I think based on what the
director and based on what Namco has
said I think we'll see Dark Souls 2 for
PC a few weeks after the console release
I think the reason we don't know yet is
because they don't know I think they're
focusing completely on consoles at the
moment and they don't know how long it
will take to polish up the PC port so
Michael asks a really sad question our
ragdoll physics gone yeah they're gone I
can't find any enemy in the game that
turns into a ragdoll when it falls onto
the ground and this is really sad
because you know when you were waiting
for a summon or something it was always
fun to play soccer with the ragdolls
but I think there's actually a lot of
spells in the game that affect corpses
so I think that's why they don't move
but it's just not a part of the engine
anymore so 800-meter asks are you part
of the glorious pc master race and yes
yes I am I picked up a PC when Dark
Souls came to PC because I wanted a way
to capture Dark Souls footage without
to buy a capture card and that worked
out really well because the PC port of
Dark Souls looked terrible at the start
but now it looks amazing with mods and
just being able to play on PC is an
awesome experience and if you're looking
to get into PC gaming now's a good time
to do it because they're really hyping
up the PC version for Dark Souls 2 and
also the game looks amazing on consoles
so I can't imagine how great it's going
to look on PC the lighting effects and
the stable framerate if they can get
that to work on consoles imagine what
they'll do with PC this time around you
know so pick one American so nice ode
black knight asks is it true that you
can Parry and riposte with every
two-handed weapon because that's cool it
is cool and when you're two handing a
weapon now l/2 actually parries with
that weapon so you don't need a shield
to parry anymore so that fact alone
makes this new mechanic really good also
when you hold down triangle instead of
just tapping it you will to hand your
left handed weapon instead of you're
right handed weapon so so much variety
this time around so vox s asks will npc
mouths move when they talk it's almost
2014 it has to happen so in Dark Souls 2
I don't think their mouths move um but
the NPC's actually make an effort to
look at you and engage with you and talk
to you and move gestures and gesticulate
so their mouths don't move but I think
they're getting there all right next
question
Hyper Souls asks which has been the most
interesting enemy and which has been the
most difficult enemy to defeat in terms
of most interesting enemy I think I
would have to say that gray Knight I've
shown in a few pieces of footage just
because I don't know what his deal is um
he starts off just sitting there looking
really down and if you attack in me
kills you and he has this really awesome
moves set because some of these attacks
they messed with your mind there's one
way he just stops moving for a while and
then he does this mad dash at you and
attacks you just when you think way what
the hell's going on he does this - it
you in a taxi and there's also another
one where he dashes to one side then he
runs the other way and dashes to another
side so it's almost like he has these
really erratic movements and that makes
him hard to predict in terms of why he's
interesting though
he's always just sitting there and you
do encounter him a bit later on the game
and he has the same behavior so I'm sure
we'll find out what the deal is with him
he's actually really difficult too but I
don't want to say the same enemy as
being difficult in terms of the most
difficult I wouldn't say it's one enemy
I'd say it's multiple enemies you know
when you're fighting multiple at once
that's when the game becomes really hard
because movement tracking is really
really good this time around not that
you can't avoid attacks
it's just that enemy attacks will clip
you and enemy attacks if it a targeted
and enemy AI is so much better so
fighting three at once that's not easy
in this game next question is by all
tamiya DC he says what I'd like to know
is is the law easily obtained this is
something I might have mentioned in a
few other videos but it's really really
interesting there's this shallow subplot
to Dark Souls where even just the most
casual player will understand what's
going on as soon as you start the game
you know that you're a cursed undead and
as soon as you get to the first starting
area NPCs tell you what's going on in
the world do I think that ruins the law
no not at all that's what I want I want
people to get into this law and to be
interested in the story of the game but
at the same time I want there to be this
deep subplot that has so much depth and
I think that's what we're going to get
in Dark Souls 2 we're going to get a
shallow bit of lore for the casual
players but we're also going to get this
depth to the law that makes it really
awesome to explore so next question is
by eye of eternity who asks will Dark
Souls 2 be on next-gen consoles and this
is a really interesting question because
I feel like even if it was we wouldn't
know about it until much later it
wouldn't be in the best interest for the
publisher to push this when the game is
coming out of ps3 now so even if it is I
don't know if we'll know about it for a
long time do I think it will come to
next-gen consoles maybe if the game
doesn't sell though and ps3 they might
think about porting over to next-gen
consoles or if next-gen consoles are
really really picked up by people then
you know I think they might think about
releasing on next-gen but for now no
it's not coming out
and I don't think you should think about
it if you're looking for an extra
experience just by little PC next
question comes in from good issues who
says are you thinking of doing a let's
play for dark souls2 after your first
playthrough and it's a good question if
I was ever going to do a full one let's
play of dark souls 2 you know the entire
playthrough it would be my first
playthrough of Dark Souls and the only
time you're going to see anything
resembling let's play content for me is
around the launch of Dark Souls 2 and I
think that's just because that's when I
see Let's Plays as being the most
valuable as to why I don't do them in
general it's because I never really saw
this channel as a really personality
driven channel I've always wanted it to
be driven by content so you're going to
see very little let's play content on
this channel and if you see anything
resembling it it will be highlight reels
and really focused content because
that's what I'm about a noble smash says
how different is the invading and
summoning of other players this is a
huge topic because it's one of the areas
where a lot of things have changed but
at the same time a lot of stuff is still
the same invading has changed in that
you can get invaded whether you're human
or Hollow
but that said don't freak out because
there are ways to avoid it
the more Hollow you get the lower the
link to other players in other worlds
and the more human you are the higher
your link to other worlds so you'll be
able to summon and you'll be able to get
invaded as well to better cover the
topic of invading I'm going to read some
more questions
Zen daddy asks does humanity work
differently that's the first part of his
question and yes humanity isn't in the
game anymore but it's been replaced by
something called a human effigy and
essentially this is humanity except you
don't have to burn it at the bonfire in
order to restore your humanity all you
have to do is consume it and this is a
really easy way to restore that humanity
and he says I heard it was going to work
a bit differently also is there a way to
make sure you don't get invaded even
though it can happen in both holo and
human state so like I said before you
get invaded more when you're human and
less when you're Hollow and there are
other ways to stop yourself being
invaded on one of them I think is when
you burn a human effigy at the bonfire
that reduces your link to other people
and this third question should really
sum up the topic there's a lot of fear
about invading and Malthus now says the
biggest thing I'm worried about
right now is that we can be invaded
while Hollow don't get me wrong I like
the idea that he's worried it will make
the game unplayable as people find ways
to exploit it and all that so his
question is do we know if anything is
being done to keep PvP balanced and it
is a good question and there is things
being done in Dark Souls you know you
could get invaded at any point by
players who were way over geared and way
more skilled than you but in Dark Souls
2 you can only be invaded by people
around your skill level and the
algorithm for invading has changed now
you invade people who are around your
skill level and by that I mean they've
got the same amount of souls through you
throughout the game they are at the same
stage in the game and they've invaded
people around the same time or they've
had the same PvP interaction that you
have so they'll be much less twinkie if
this works the way they intended to and
in terms of invader balancing and summon
balancing in terms of PvP it's really
hard to get a feel for it at this point
because we haven't experienced the game
enough but there are a lot of covenants
that actually affect PvP interaction one
of them protects you when you get
invaded another one lets you protect
people when they get invaded and you
know this sort of thing is a way of
building into the game ways to protect
yourself from twinken and that sort of
thing without just locking it out
entirely anyway that's enough about
invading I'm glad this next question
came up though it's by David McGuire he
says will there be a hub area like in
Demon Souls
or will the worlds be mostly seamless
like in Dark Souls
so in Demon Souls you had this hub area
where you could go back to rest level up
by equipment talk to NPCs and then you
went out into the world but in Dark
Souls the hub area was intertwined with
other areas and while you could walk
from the bonfire you can still go from
filing to any other area in the world
so in duck sells to the new hub area is
called majula and you can tell that they
tried to capture a lot of what the Nexus
was in Demon Souls because there's a lot
of that vibe of but you know I have to
come back to this area to rest and to
gather my wits and think about my next
plan and level up and talk to NPCs and
buy equipment and they're really
cementing this new hub area called
majula as this place of rest that was
more like the hub in Demon Souls than in
and I say that because you actually have
to level up in this hub area by talking
to a maiden just like you did in Demon
Souls and while you might think this
breaks the flow a little bit it really
doesn't coming back to the duel that
feels like you know you're planning your
next move and you have this time to rest
and while it does break up the gameplay
a little you know you've been a boss so
you have to go back to medulla I really
like that change and I'm glad it's a mix
of both Firelink where it's seamless
with the world but it's also Demon Souls
where you have to go there and rest all
right so this next question is by Lord
loudmouth he says in the wake of healing
crystals have the developers somehow
limited the use of Estus flasks so that
you can't simply chug in Estus while the
healing crystals work so healing and
Dark Souls 2 has changed so much that we
really have to play through the entire
game to get a feel for how well it's
balanced but I really like the changes
they've implemented and they've changed
estes in a way that now estes you know
the start of the game now in Dark Souls
2 you're going to start with one Estus
flask not 5:1 and while it's the same
strength as the other ones from Dark
Souls you only start with one and this
really teaches you the value of estes
you'll never really get to the point
where you're chugging it you know you'll
value it and estes is now this in in
combat healing item whereas life gems
are more of it in between combat but
they're also consumable and they are not
found throughout the world that much so
to answer your question which i think
was our healing items overpowered no i
don't think they are you can't just
charge estes and use live gems at the
same time the life gems are really
valuable and estes is really valuable
and you know you do learn the value of
these things through the game now we're
getting near the end of the questions
now and i think i covered most of really
really common ones this next question is
by manager ER and he says how was the
framerate on the ps3 in the TGS server
in the ps3 beta test i wasn't 30 frames
per second all the time with this you
have to remember that the TGS demo was
really really polished because it was
something they were putting out to the
public but the beta definitely wasn't as
polished as the TGS demo was and that
showed in the frame rate and also the
gameplay a little bit to an extent the
TGS demo framerate was stable it was
really stable until you got to the
marinade which had so many particle
effects from what I've played in Dark
Souls and that's you know the more
recent versions of Dark Souls the
framerate is incredibly stable
considering the particle effect and the
lighting going on the resolution isn't
great but the frame rate is brilliant
and I think framerate is so much more
valuable than resolution is so to have a
stable framerate in Dark Souls 2 is an
amazing feat on ps3 and yeah the frame
rate is great so I don't think you need
to worry about that from what I've seen
so we're going to go back to healing for
a second guys because alex asks how does
the estus flask work I don't see a plus
1 or 2 at the end and yet it still heals
all of your HP as to why it heals most
of Mike HP that's because you've only
seen Dark Souls 2 at the start of the
game you haven't seen it at the end of
the game and at the end of the game you
know when you get more vitality your
Estus flask and upgraded isn't going to
heal all of your HP but we haven't
really talked about how to upgrade your
Estus flask and that's something that's
changed in order to get more than one
Estus flask in Dark Souls 2 you need to
bring Estus shards to the maiden the
maiden will then let you carry more than
one Estus flask in order to make your
Estus flask heal more you actually have
to burn a type of consumable item at the
bonfire and this allows your Estus flask
to heal more of your health the next set
of questions are by user salty waffles
who has three questions the first of
which is do enemies still have the exact
same placement every time and this
answer is twofold because there is a way
to change and any placements as you get
to a certain point in the game but I'm
not going to spoil that for you right
now the other way enemy placements
change is that now if you kill the same
enemy like 15 times over and over again
that one enemy will eventually stop
respawning there's still a bit of
experimentation we have to do with this
and I know you're probably thinking oh
that dulls down the game for the player
you know it makes it forgiving if
they're really having trouble with a
level and I understand why they put it
in they want
get rid of the tedium but you're going
to have to decide you know is that too
much do you dislike the fact that some
enemies will stop respawning in order to
make the game easier I think they just
did it because a lot of the time you
know you run the same area on the way to
the boss and whenever I've had this
happened to me it's because I died like
20 times to the same boss and having
those enemies go away was nice and since
I was just running past them it wasn't
that bad but you will have to make that
decision is that too easy for you salty
waffles this next question is about Joe
welding and it's already been answered
but his third question is about
crossbows and it's in three parts he
says I crossbows finally functional
weapons as in can they be aimed like a
bow fired while moving and not have to
be reloaded immediately after firing so
the first bit can they be aimed like a
boat they can be aimed in first-person
so I assume that's what you mean
five volleying I think actually the
difference between crossbows and bows
this time around is that bows can't be
fired while moving but we'll have to see
but I'm pretty sure that's the case and
the third bit not have to be reloaded
immediately after firing they do have to
be reloaded I'm quite sure to be ready
for the next round all right guys last
question is by Ogami 23 who says how do
you feel about the making Dark Souls 2
instead of a new Souls game and you know
I was a little disappointed when they
announced Dark Souls 2 because I really
liked the sound of Dragon souls or
something like that and I really liked
the naming scheme of the souls series
you know you can change it up you don't
have to put two at the end all you have
to do is change that first word which is
dark or demons or dragon so whatever you
want it to be I'm glad it's a sequel to
Dark Souls because I think Dark Souls is
universe has way more potential to
explore and there's so many unanswered
questions so I'm glad we get a bit of
finality so in the end I'm really glad
they made Dark Souls 2 alright that does
it for me for the day guys if you have a
question that wasn't answered and that's
pretty likely considering there were
5000 of them just leave it below I'll be
answering the questions in this comment
section pretty much exclusively over the
next few days so just leave it there if
you had a question other than that
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next one Cheers
you